il connaît absolument pas là-dedans
à qui parler ou m'informer à
l'excarpentier fait partie de ceux dont
le vol a été longuement retardé par
Sunwing c'est probabilité de partir vers
le sud fonde maintenant comme neige au
soleil ouais c'est la première fois que
ça m'arrive et n'ayant jamais vécu une
telle situation il peine à s'y retrouver
mais depuis septembre dernier les
voyageurs comme Alex Carpentier sont
mieux protégés par la loi canadienne si
un vol est annulé ou sérieusement
prolongé même si la situation est hors
du contrôle des transporteurs comme la
météo une réservation pour un vol dans
les 48 prochaines heures doit être faite
et si cela est impossible c'est un
remboursement dans les 30 jours qui
s'appliquent désormais
le 25 décembre ils l'ont remis à 7h le
soir pour l'instant aucun recours on
doit d'attendre le vol finalement du 25
décembre à 7h a pas lieu rapporté au 26
15 décembre à 7h le matin là vous avez
le droit de demander à la compagnie
aérienne un remboursement complet sur
votre vote de l'autre côté de la
frontière on sent les autorités
proactives suite au cafouillage de sorte
ouest Airlines et de ses milliers de
vols annulés pour la Maison Blanche la
compagnie doit être tenue responsable
aux États-Unis les droits des passagers
sont rigoureusement encadrés par une
charte des voyageurs un document qui
existe au Canada que depuis 2019 et qui
pourrait aller plus loin et là-bas
l'avantage c'est que le fardeau de la
preuve c'est sur le dos des compagnies
aériennes alors que chez nous c'est le
passagers c'est dans ce passager de
montrer que la situation ne permettait
pas à la compagnie d'assurer un bon aux
États-Unis c'est l'inverse en date du 20
décembre plus de 31000 pleines pour
annulation ou retard de vol était en
attente à l'Office des transports du
Canada avec le chaos les derniers jours
d'autres s'ajouteront inévitablement
mais il est cependant trop tôt pour en
connaître l'étendue ici aimer Lemieux
Radio-Canada Montréal